wir hatten so eine großartige nacht
heute schauen wir uns all die
bundesstadt an gewicht gewonnen haben
und dann schauen wir uns mal an mit
welchem sind nach 60 prozent übrig wir
haben starken und ich dachte mir was ist
mittellos da stimmt was nicht
was ist los sondern haben sie gesagt
dass sie was passiert ist sie wussten
dass sie nichts gewinnen können und
deshalb haben sie gesagt wir gehen vor
gericht habe ich das nicht vorher gesagt
habe ich das nicht wie man an dem tag an
dem es hieß millionen von briefwählern
habe ich gesagt das wird an gerichtshof
enden betrug nahm ich amerikanischen
volk das ist kein licht für unser land
wir haben uns bereit gemacht diese wahl
zu gewinnen und ich wollte mal sagen wir
haben sie bei gewonnen
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin jetzt sicher
zu stellen dass die integrität dieses
volkes oder sich hätte das ist ein
großer moment gerade das ist wirklich
wichtig wir wollen dass das recht aufs
richtige art und weise genutzt wird und
dass wir gehen wird zum obersten
gerichtshof und wir wollen wählen auf
man kann keine wahlzettel von vier uhr
morgens am nächsten tag könnten uns die
immer noch auf der liste schreiben das
ist doch traurig das ist ein trauriger
moment für mich
wir werden gewinnen und weiß haben
und deswegen möchte ich euch zeigt wir
sind bild und wir liefert dir deine news
auf youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren